I invested 100 pesos in Cetes each week.
This is the first week I will invest
100 pesos in cet and I will perform it
for 50:02 weeks of the year
in order to create the habit of saving
and that money does not lose value against inflation
and for those who do not know Cetes,
Cetes is Mexico's safest investment
and you can start investing from 100 pesos.
It is an excellent option
to stop saving on the piggy bank
and as you can see I already have my 100 pesos in
in my direct cetes account,
we are going to invest,
we are going to give you in the investment instrument z
and will display us to see the options
one month,
three months,
6 months,
one year and up to two years.
In this first week
I am going to invest within two years
because it is giving above 10%.
and I want to tie that cup
for two years,
I am going to give the two-year option,
I am going to deposit that I want to invest 100 pesos
as it is the minimum amount you ask me to do
and the amount I will invest each week.
I will only accept him
to generate our investment order
and that's it.
That's as easy as that
I have invested my first 100 pesos in Cetes Direct.
Every week I will be
sharing how I am investing in Cetes live,
so I invite you to follow me
to learn more about Investment and Finance